– Also: Was habt ihr vor?
– Das ist eigentlich ganz einfach.
Wir wollen unserem Restaurant
einen Lieferservice anschließen.
– Das willst du doch schon lange.
– Aber jetzt hab ich jemanden gefunden,
der mich unterstützt.
– Pepe.
Ernsthaft?
– Das könnte sehr profitabel werden!
– Ich verstehe.
Und was hab ich damit zu tun?
– Ich möchte, dass der Lieferservice
umweltfreundlich ist.
– Deshalb wollen wir
mit dem Fahrrad liefern.
Das ist umweltfreundlich
und spart auch Benzinkosten.
– Das geht zwar nicht, wenn es schneit,
aber ansonsten eigentlich immer.
– Und ihr wollt Fahrräder von mir.
– Ja, aber nicht nur Fahrräder.
Das Geschäft soll sich auch
sonst für dich lohnen.
– Wie denn?
– Na ja, du steigst in das Projekt als
Geschäftspartnerin mit ein und
wirst dann am Gewinn beteiligt.
– Das Risiko wird dann
natürlich auch geteilt.
– Wenn dir der Vorschlag zu riskant ist,
dann mieten wir die Fahrräder
einfach nur bei dir.
Und auf unserem Flyer und in der App
wird dann Werbung
für deinen Laden gemacht.
– Die Idee ist gut.
Aber ich kann jetzt
keinen Kredit aufnehmen.
– Das ist vielleicht gar nicht nötig.
– Wieso?
– Ich kenne einen Investor,
der Interesse hat.
– Einen Investor?
Wie groß soll das Geschäft
mit dem Lieferservice denn werden?
– Na ja, so groß es geht.